Parents and adults may get as much fun out
of Disney and Pixar movies, but it's assumed
that the actual stories and humor won't be
anything too mature for younger audiences.
But sometimes, the people actually making
the movie just can't help themselves - sliding
in crude jokes or adult gags that can't be
unseen, and are almost guaranteed to have
older viewers laughing... and wondering how
they ever could have missed them the first
time around.
In some cases you won’t even believe how
these scenes are actually part of the movies.
Here is Screenrant's look at Dirty Disney:
10 Inappropriate Scenes in Disney Films.
Toy Story 3
There are some adult jokes that go over kids'
heads, and then there are ones that are subtle
enough to be missed even by parents.
In Toy Story 3, the gang learns just how rude
the villain Lotso really is when he pulls
off the mouth of Mrs. Potato Head just to
shut her up.
As they look on stunned, Mr Potato Head lets
Lotso know that only her husband is allowed
to pull that trick, delivering a veiled sex
joke in the process.
Kids in the audience were probably too scared
to notice their parents eyes widening at that
one.
Inside Out
Since the movie takes place inside the mind
of a preteen girl, Inside Out is a fairly
innocent story about leaving childhood behind
as a family moves from Minnesota to San Francisco.
But the writers couldn't resist making one
tiny joke given the city's famous history
in the gay rights movement.
When the emotions run wild upon seeing their
new house, Fear wonders if deadly bears live
in the city, with Anger claiming to have seen
one already.
The line is meaningless to kids, but adults
will realize the term is typically used in
the gay community to describe large, hairy
men.
Anger had no idea.
Aladdin: King of Thieves
There are plenty of Disney fans who name Aladdin
as their favorite, so the two straight to
home video sequels that followed were no surprise.
But apparently, the studio figured nobody
was paying attending by the third in the series.
So when Aladdin and princess Jasmine are finally
set to get married, a sudden attack on the
castle gives Genie the opportunity for one
of his signature one-liners.
Making a sex joke about the young couple wasn't
too inappropriate, but it shows just how much
can slip by unnoticed when you talk as fast
as Robin Williams.
The Emperor's New Groove
Not every crude joke is without some clever
humor - and sometimes, the best gags don't
even have to be called out to get fans laughing.
The Emperor's New Groove saw Kronk out camping
in an extremely small tent.
When audiences realize they're watching as
he "pitches a tent" confined to his crotch,
they may realize that half of Disney's humor
may have gone by completely unnoticed.
But that might be for the best.
Cars
Pixar's automotive adventure begins with Star
Lightning McQueen at the top of his game,
the most famous racer in America.
So famous, he even had groupies in the form
of two shapely young sports cars.
When viewers realize that their decision to
show their high beams to the racer actually
means that he's being flashed, the dozens
of camera flashes make a lot more sense...
And guarantee you'll think twice about every
other set of headlights in the rest of the
movie.
Surprisingly, that's not even the only adult
joke made in the movie, as a later scene shows
a roadside restaurant called the Top Down
Truckstop.
In case audience members didn't get the reference,
the sign also advertises "all convertible
waitresses" - that's right, a topless truckstop,
right under viewers' noses.
Frozen
We know, there's no way Disney's heartwarming,
billion dollar tale of sisterly love had anything
crude, right?
When Anna first joins forces with Kristof,
he's less than supportive about her marrying
a man she just met, proving it's a bad move
by quizzing her about Hans, including his
foot size.
It's a safe bet the women in the audience
gave the line a giggle, since it's an obvious
play on the idea that "size doesn't matter"
when it comes to a man's... equipment.
Hercules
Disney's version of the classical Greek hero
took a different approach to designing Mythical
creatures, and the Centaur stands out as a
particularly odd one.
Not only does the creatures entire head seem
modelled after a part of the male anatomy,
but when Hercules sends the beast skyward,
he lands hard - resulting in a massive bruise
swelling off the top of his head.
If the suggestive shape of his skull passed
any viewers by, his knobby brow and massive
lump show that Disney's animators can still
be as immature as their audience.
Ratatouille
When Linguini is finally forced to admit that
it's his pet rat who is cooking award-winning
food, and not him, it's his hopeful romance
Colette that he lets in on the secret.
But when trying to explain the tiny little
truth he's hiding, it's impossible to miss
Colette's grimace, and quick glance below
Linguini's waist.
It's a joke aimed squarely at the older fans,
and is just subtle enough to sneak by without
offending anyone.
Bambi
That's right, even back in 1942 Disney was
slipping some sly adult humor into family
entertainment.
Although Bambi is the star of the show, his
good friend Flower the skunk is just as memorable.
When Flower first runs into Bluebelle, the
pair share a kiss that renders him completely
frozen.
It's a cute and harmless joke, but once people
realized a kiss made Flower flush with blood
and grow as stiff as a board, it was obvious
the animators were implying something that
kids hopefully wouldn't ask any questions
about.
Those are the best adult jokes we found hidden
in Disney and Pixar movies, but are there
any we missed?
Be sure to share your own favorite gags in
the comments, and subscribe to this channel
for more videos like this one.